bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Wattrus e sou o diretor
técnico de educação na IBM Quantum. Esta é a 11ª aula da série e é a terceira aula da
terceira unidade, que trata da formulação geral da informação quântica. Esta aula é sobre medições, que representam uma
interface entre informação quântica e clássica. Quando uma medição é realizada em um sistema enquanto ele está em um
Estado Quântico, informação clássica é extraída, revelando algo sobre esse Estado Quântico e geralmente alterando ou
destruindo esse estado no processo. Em uma formulação simplificada da informação quântica que foi discutida
na primeira unidade da série, tipicamente restringimos nossa atenção a medições projetivas, incluindo o
tipo mais simples de medição: as medições de base padrão. É possível, no entanto, generalizar a noção de medição,
e isso acaba sendo bastante útil. Nesta aula, vamos falar sobre medições em total generalidade,
incluindo como elas são descritas em termos matemáticos e como se encaixam na formulação geral da informação
quântica. No final da aula, também vamos dar uma olhada em alguns conceitos fundamentais relacionados às medições: discriminação de Estado Quântico
e tomografia de Estado Quântico. Então vamos começar! Aqui está uma visão geral da
aula. Como costumamos fazer, vamos começar com o básico, incluindo dois modos diferentes, mas equivalentes, de
descrever medições em termos matemáticos. Em particular, podemos descrever medições por coleções de matrizes,
e também podemos descrevê-las como canais, o que mencionei na aula anterior. Também vamos discutir
medições parciais, ou seja, medições que são realizadas em apenas uma parte de um sistema composto
maior. Em seguida, passamos ao teorema de Neymark, que é um fato fundamental sobre medições que basicamente
diz que medições gerais sempre podem ser implementadas de uma forma simples que lembra as representações de Stinespring
de canais. Em resumo, medições gerais sempre podem ser implementadas introduzindo primeiro um
sistema de espaço de trabalho inicializado, depois realizando uma operação unitária e finalmente realizando uma medição de base padrão
no sistema de espaço de trabalho. Isso acaba sendo bastante fácil de provar, e vamos ver como funciona.
Também vamos ver como isso se conecta às chamadas medições não destrutivas, que vou descrever. Por fim, na última parte da
aula, vamos discutir discriminação de Estado Quântico e tomografia de Estado Quântico. Vamos começar com as
descrições matemáticas de medições. Medições nos fornecem uma interface entre informação quântica e
clássica. Quando uma medição é realizada em um sistema enquanto ele está em algum Estado Quântico, informação clássica
sobre esse estado quântico é extraída. Além disso, o estado quântico é geralmente alterado ou possivelmente
completamente destruído. Inicialmente, vamos focar nossa atenção nas chamadas medições destrutivas, onde
um Estado Quântico entra e apenas informação clássica sai — portanto, não há especificação do
estado quântico pós-medição do sistema que foi medido. Intuitivamente, podemos imaginar que uma medição destrutiva
destrói qualquer sistema que foi medido, de forma que seu estado após a medição não é
especificado. Isso não significa literalmente que dispositivos físicos são necessariamente destruídos — é apenas uma
descrição matemática, e é uma muito útil, porque ajuda a manter as coisas simples e focar nos aspectos matemáticos essenciais
das medições. Existem em particular duas formas equivalentes de descrever medições destrutivas,
que mencionei durante a visão geral da aula. Uma forma de descrever uma medição destrutiva
é por uma coleção de matrizes, onde em particular temos uma Matriz para cada possível resultado da
medição. Uma segunda forma de descrever uma medição destrutiva é por um canal, onde a
entrada é o estado de qualquer sistema que está sendo medido e a saída é sempre uma Matriz de densidade diagonal, que podemos
interpretar como uma descrição de uma distribuição de probabilidade sobre os possíveis resultados clássicos da
medição. As duas descrições são equivalentes, e isso é bastante útil porque nos permite escolher qualquer descrição que for mais conveniente em uma
dada situação. Também vamos falar sobre medições não destrutivas, onde além de um resultado clássico da
medição, o estado quântico pós-medição do sistema que foi medido também é
especificado. Medições não destrutivas são importantes e aparecem com frequência, mas há um sentido em que elas
não são tão fundamentais quanto as medições destrutivas em termos matemáticos. Em particular, como veremos,
medições não destrutivas sempre podem ser descritas como composições de canais e medições destrutivas, e
vamos ver como isso funciona um pouco mais tarde na aula. Agora vamos ver como medições — ou seja, medições destrutivas —
podem ser descritas como coleções de matrizes. Ao longo dessa discussão, vamos supor que X é um sistema que está
sendo medido e, por simplicidade, vamos fazer algumas suposições. Primeiro, vamos assumir que o
conjunto de estados clássicos de X consiste nos inteiros de 0 a n menos um para algum inteiro positivo n, e os possíveis
resultados da medição são os inteiros de 0 a M menos um, novamente para algum inteiro positivo M. Não
precisa haver nenhuma relação entre os números n e M — ambos são inteiros positivos arbitrários, e é claro que poderíamos substituir
esses conjuntos por conjuntos de estados clássicos arbitrários se quiséssemos. Primeiro, vamos relembrar como funcionam as medições projetivas,
sobre as quais falamos pela primeira vez na terceira aula da série. Dado que estamos assumindo que os
resultados da medição são os inteiros de 0 a n menos um, descrevemos uma medição projetiva por uma coleção
de projeções Pi 0 até Pi M menos um que somam à Matriz identidade, e essas matrizes têm linhas e
colunas correspondentes aos estados clássicos de X — em outras palavras, são todas matrizes n por n.
Se x está em um Estado Quântico descrito por um Vetor de Estado Quântico s, então cada possível resultado da
medição a aparece com probabilidade igual à norma euclidiana ao quadrado de Pi a multiplicada
pelo vetor s. A norma euclidiana ao quadrado de qualquer vetor é igual ao produto interno desse
vetor com ele mesmo, então obtemos a expressão mostrada na tela, e podemos simplificar isso um
pouco usando o fato de que Pi a é uma projeção, então multiplicá-la por si mesma não faz
nada. E por fim podemos reescrever a expressão obtida de uma forma ligeiramente diferente, usando a propriedade cíclica
do traço, como mostrado na tela. E se não está claro por que queremos escrever a expressão assim, a
resposta curta é que gostaríamos de entender como as medições projetivas funcionam para
matrizes de densidade. E em particular, por linearidade, se o estado de X for descrito por uma Matriz de densidade rho em vez
de um Vetor de Estado Quântico s, então a probabilidade para o resultado a aparecer é dada pelo traço da projeção
Pi a vezes a Matriz de densidade rho. Isso precisa ser o caso porque, como vimos,
podemos sempre pensar em uma Matriz de densidade como sendo uma média ponderada de estados puros, e se fizermos a média das
probabilidades correspondentes, obtemos essa expressão porque o traço é uma função linear. Então essa é a expressão que buscamos,
e podemos organizar as coisas um pouco para focar nas
matrizes de densidade. O principal objetivo disso, a propósito, é estabelecer um ponto de referência ao que já aprendemos
e ver que essa descrição de medições projetivas é de fato um caso especial de uma descrição mais geral de medições que
vamos ver agora. Então o que farei agora é substituir essa descrição de como as medições projetivas funcionam para matrizes de densidade
pela descrição para medições gerais, para que possamos entender a relação. E aqui
está: uma medição geral — não necessariamente uma medição projetiva — é descrita por uma coleção de matrizes
positivas semi-definidas p 0 até pM menos um que somam à identidade. E se essa medição for realizada em X enquanto ele está
em um estado descrito por uma Matriz de densidade rho, então cada resultado a aparece com probabilidade igual ao traço de PA vezes
Rho. Em resumo, a única coisa que mudou é que relaxamos a condição sobre essas matrizes — em particular, as matrizes
não precisam ser matrizes de projeção, apenas precisam ser positivas semi-definidas. E correspondentemente, substituí a letra Pi pela letra p,
porque Pi é um nome convencional para uma projeção, enquanto prefiro usar a letra p para matrizes
positivas semi-definidas. Isso é uma generalização da descrição que tínhamos para medições projetivas, a propósito, porque matrizes de projeção são sempre positivas
semi-definidas, e na verdade podem ser definidas alternativamente como matrizes positivas semi-definidas cujos autovalores
só podem ser zero e um. Podemos observar que essa definição
faz sentido, pois sempre obtemos um vetor de probabilidade para as probabilidades dos resultados, da seguinte
forma: primeiro, esses números que me referi como probabilidades dos resultados são sempre números reais não negativos — isso
ocorre porque tanto PA quanto rho são positivos semi-definidos, e o traço do produto de duas matrizes positivas semi-definidas
é sempre um número real não negativo — e deixo para você pensar por quê isso é
assim. E segundo, os números precisam somar um porque o traço é linear,
as matrizes p 0 até pN menos 1 precisam somar à identidade, e as matrizes de densidade têm traço igual a
um. Então, independentemente de qual Matriz de densidade rho começamos, as probabilidades dos resultados formarão sempre um
vetor de probabilidade. Agora vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos. Já mencionei que
medições projetivas são um caso especial de medições gerais, porque projeções são sempre positivas semi-definidas.
Mas é bom começar simples, então vamos começar com uma medição de base padrão de um qubit. Podemos representar uma medição de base padrão
de um qubit por duas matrizes p 0 e P1 definidas como mostrado na tela. p 0 é z bra zero e P1 é k1
bra um. Ambas são matrizes positivas semi-definidas e de fato são projeções, e claramente somam à
identidade. Portanto, juntas, descrevem uma medição. Se aplicarmos essa medição a um qubit
em um estado descrito por uma Matriz de densidade rho, então a probabilidade para o resultado zero aparecer é o traço de p 0 vezes rho,
e a probabilidade para o resultado um é o traço de P1 vezes rho. E pela propriedade cíclica do traço, obtemos
as duas entradas diagonais de rho, como esperado. Aqui está outro exemplo, onde desta vez
as matrizes não são projeções. Elas são positivas semi-definidas, e de fato são matrizes de densidade,
mas isso não é importante. O que é importante é que elas somam à identidade, de forma que juntas descrevem uma
medição. Podemos ver o que acontece quando essa medição é realizada em um qubit no estado mais, por exemplo,
apenas para ver como funciona num exemplo de estado. E um cálculo das probabilidades é mostrado na
tela. Note em particular que, embora o estado mais seja um estado puro e possamos representar esse estado pelo vetor de estado quântico cat Mais, temos
que substituir a representação em Matriz de densidade desse estado, que é C mais BR mais, nas fórmulas para obter
as probabilidades. E deixa eu também observar que, como estamos falando sobre uma medição destrutiva, não há
especificação do estado quântico pós-medição deste qubit. Então tudo que temos é a especificação das
probabilidades dos resultados. Aqui está um último exemplo por enquanto, e é bem interessante. Mais uma vez é uma medição de um
único qubit, e para descrevê-la vamos começar definindo quatro vetores de estado quântico conhecidos como os
estados tetraédricos. A razão pela qual são chamados de estados tetraédricos é porque correspondem aos quatro vértices de
um tetraedro regular inscrito na esfera de Bloch. E para ficar claro, quando dizemos que é um tetraedro regular
queremos dizer um sólido de quatro faces onde cada uma das faces é um triângulo equilátero. Então há uma simetria perfeita aqui —
cada aresta tem o mesmo comprimento e é o mesmo ângulo formado entre quaisquer duas arestas
adjacentes. E agora podemos definir uma medição interessante com quatro possíveis resultados, como mostrado na tela. Em palavras, podemos tomar nossas
matrizes como sendo as representações em Matriz de densidade desses estados divididas por dois. Agora essas são definitivamente matrizes positivas
semi-definidas porque são matrizes de densidade divididas por dois, e você poderia fazer a aritmética para verificar
que elas de fato somam à identidade. Mas outra forma de ver isso é pensar na simetria: se fizermos a média desses quatro estados
juntos, obtemos o estado completamente misturado, que está no centro da esfera de Bloch. Mas como estamos dividindo
cada um por dois em vez de quatro, obtemos o dobro do estado completamente misturado, que é a identidade. Não vou dizer nada mais sobre
essa medição por enquanto, exceto observar que não é uma medição projetiva — mas é um bom exemplo, e
vamos vê-la aparecer novamente mais tarde na aula. Outra forma de descrever medições gerais é como canais, como vamos
discutir agora. A ideia aqui é que estados probabilísticos clássicos podem ser representados por matrizes de densidade diagonais, e portanto,
como os resultados das medições são clássicos, podemos pensar nas medições como sendo canais onde a saída é sempre uma Matriz de densidade diagonal
que descreve o resultado da medição. Então vamos dar uma olhada nisso com um pouco mais de detalhe. Se pensarmos
de forma abstrata sobre uma medição geral, podemos descrever essa medição como um canal fi. O sistema de entrada para o canal é
qualquer sistema X que está sendo medido, e o sistema de saída é um sistema y cujos estados clássicos correspondem aos
resultados da medição, que estamos tomando como sendo os inteiros de 0 a n menos um para algum inteiro positivo
M. E como os resultados das medições são clássicos, exigimos que para toda Matriz de densidade de entrada rho para o sistema
X, a saída fi rho seja uma Matriz de densidade diagonal. Por exemplo, se pensarmos sobre uma
medição de base padrão de um qubit e pensarmos nessa medição como sendo descrita por um canal, podemos expressá-la como temos aqui na tela.
Se a Matriz de densidade de entrada for rho, então obteremos o resultado zero com probabilidade igual a bra 0 rho cat Zero
e obteremos o resultado um com probabilidade bra um rho Kat um. E então, se expressarmos esses
resultados clássicos de medição como matrizes de densidade, obteremos essa expressão para o Canal correspondente, e acontece
que é exatamente o canal de defasagem completa. E isso é consistente com a ideia de que o canal de defasagem completa
representa uma forma extrema de decoerência — o que pode significar coisas diferentes, mas quando uso esse termo estou
falando sobre a tendência dos estados quânticos de se tornarem clássicos porque o ambiente ao redor de qualquer sistema do qual estamos
falando está "observando" de certa forma — ou seja, está medindo.
Então os resultados da medição podem ser descritos como canais, como acabei de descrever. Mas isso não é apenas uma possibilidade — é uma
caracterização de medições gerais. E o que quero dizer com isso é o seguinte: é claro que existem canais
que não representam medições, porque a saída pode não ser sempre uma Matriz de densidade diagonal. Mas se for o
caso de que a saída de um canal é sempre uma Matriz de densidade diagonal, independentemente do estado de entrada rho que escolhemos, então é necessariamente possível
expressar esse canal na forma mostrada na tela para alguma escolha de uma medição — ou seja, uma coleção de
matrizes positivas semi-definidas que somam à identidade. E isso é bom por várias razões, incluindo o fato de que nos
diz basicamente que nossa definição de medições como coleções de matrizes não está
deixando nada de fora. Outra forma de dizer isso é que essa forma de pensar sobre medições como canais é operacional,
ou talvez axiomática, no sentido de que captura o que uma medição deve ser — que é um processo físico que
transforma informação quântica em informação clássica. E resulta que é completamente equivalente à nossa primeira
descrição de medições, que é puramente algébrica. Não vou mostrar a prova da equivalência neste vídeo, mas
não é difícil, e se você tiver interesse pode encontrar a prova no material escrito da aula, que está linkado na descrição
do vídeo. Discutimos o que acontece quando uma medição geral é realizada em um sistema em um dado estado,
pelo menos para o caso de medições destrutivas. A seguir, vamos falar sobre medições parciais, ou seja, quando apenas
uma parte de um sistema composto é medida. Para ser preciso, vamos supor que temos um par de sistemas XZ que
juntos estão em um estado descrito por uma Matriz de densidade rho, e uma medição descrita por uma coleção de matrizes positivas semi-definidas que somam à
identidade é realizada no sistema X sozinho. Naturalmente, isso resulta em um
resultado da medição, e como estamos falando sobre medições destrutivas, podemos imaginar que o processo de medição destrói o sistema
X. Mas ainda temos o sistema Z com o qual nos preocupar, e precisamos entender como a medição de X afeta o
estado de Z. Primeiro, vamos falar sobre as probabilidades dos
resultados. Como estamos falando sobre uma medição do sistema X sozinho, as probabilidades para diferentes
resultados aparecerem só podem depender do estado de X isoladamente — ou seja, só podem depender do
estado reduzido de X. Em particular, a probabilidade para um dado resultado a aparecer é dada pela
mesma fórmula de antes, que é o traço de PA vezes o estado reduzido de X, que denotamos por rho
sub x. O estado rho sub x é obtido de rho traçando Z. Então podemos fazer essa
substituição, e embora possa não ser imediatamente óbvio, a expressão que obtemos pode ser alternativamente escrita como é
mostrado na tela. É o traço de PA tensor com a Matriz identidade no sistema Z vezes
rho. Agora essa é uma igualdade que definitivamente vale a pena verificar com calma. É intuitiva —
não estamos fazendo nada em Z, então faz sentido que a identidade em Z apareça assim. Mas também pode ser verificada
algebricamente, e deixo isso para você, junto com a sugestão de primeiro considerar o caso em que rho é um produto tensor de duas matrizes, e então
usar linearidade para concluir que deve funcionar para todo rho. E também digo que isso não depende do fato de que PA
é positivo semi-definido ou de que rho é uma Matriz de densidade. Essa é uma igualdade que funcionaria para qualquer escolha de
matrizes no lugar de PA e rho, desde que tenham as dimensões certas para que a expressão faça
sentido. E agora vamos ver como o estado de Z é afetado pela medição. A abordagem natural, do meu ponto de vista,
é pensar na medição como um canal. Aqui está o canal que associamos à nossa medição — estamos
pensando nisto como um canal do sistema X para um novo sistema y cujos estados clássicos correspondem aos resultados da medição. Então nessa fórmula,
Sigma representa um estado do sistema X sozinho. Se aplicarmos esse canal ao
sistema X enquanto o par XZ está no estado rho, então obteremos a Matriz de densidade que temos aqui. Novamente,
tome o tempo que precisar para verificar isso, e novamente minha sugestão é primeiro considerar o caso em que rho é um produto tensor
de duas matrizes e depois usar linearidade. Agora vimos esse tipo de estado
onde o primeiro sistema é clássico e o segundo sistema é quântico como um exemplo na aula sobre
Matrizes de densidade. Cada a ocorre com alguma probabilidade, que é o traço do segundo fator tensor. Então você pode pensar
nesses segundos fatores tensor como sendo matrizes de densidade multiplicadas por probabilidades. Então para obter o estado de
Z condicionado a obter um resultado particular da medição a, simplesmente dividimos a probabilidade — em outras palavras,
normalizamos o segundo fator tensor dividindo-o pelo seu próprio traço. Então em resumo, se realizamos uma
medição em X enquanto o par XZ está no estado rho, é o que acontece: primeiro, cada resultado a aparece
com probabilidade igual ao traço de PA tensor com a identidade vezes rho, e segundo, condicionado a obter
um resultado particular da medição a, o estado de Z é dado pela expressão mostrada na tela, que é o que obtemos
ao normalizar a Matriz que vimos há um momento. E isso é a mesma coisa que dividir a matriz pela probabilidade
de a aparecer. Devo mencionar que isso só faz sentido se a probabilidade for diferente de zero, porque caso contrário estaríamos
dividindo por zero. Mas tudo bem, porque não precisamos nos preocupar com coisas que não acontecem. Nesta parte da
aula, vamos discutir um teorema simples mas fundamental sobre medições, conhecido como o teorema de Neymark.
Em resumo, o que ele diz é que qualquer medição pode ser implementada como a figura na tela
sugere. Colocando em palavras: uma dada medição geral em um sistema X pode ser implementada da seguinte forma:
primeiro introduzimos um sistema de espaço de trabalho inicializado y cujos estados clássicos são os possíveis resultados da medição, que estamos assumindo ser
numerados de 0 até n menos um. Depois uma operação unitária U é realizada no par
YX, e então uma medição de base padrão é realizada em y. Então tudo está basicamente
definido, exceto pela escolha de U. E o que o teorema diz é que é de fato possível escolher essa operação unitária
U de forma que as probabilidades para os diferentes resultados sempre concordem com a dada medição geral.
Agora vamos ver como o teorema de Neymark é provado — e não é difícil. Só precisamos fazer uma boa escolha para
a operação unitária U e verificar que funciona. Mas primeiro precisamos de um fato básico
da teoria de matrizes, que é que para qualquer Matriz positiva semi-definida P, sempre existe uma única Matriz positiva semi-definida
Q tal que Q ao quadrado é igual a P. Em geral, podem existir muitas matrizes que ao quadrado nos dão P, mas
sempre há exatamente uma que é positiva semi-definida. A notação que usamos para denotar essa Matriz é a raiz quadrada de
P, e é também como nos referimos a ela em palavras. Se você quiser calcular a raiz quadrada de P para alguma Matriz positiva
semi-definida P, pode fazer isso primeiro calculando uma decomposição espectral de P e depois
substituindo cada um dos autovalores pela sua raiz quadrada, deixando os autovetores em paz. Os autovalores são todos não-
negativos, então isso faz sentido, e é bastante fácil ver que a Matriz que obtemos é de fato positiva semi-definida
e ao quadrado nos dá P. O fato de que ela é única é um assunto diferente — não é difícil
provar isso usando alguns fatos básicos sobre matrizes, mas é um tanto tangencial à aula, e vamos apenas aceitar essa parte
como dada. E agora que temos esse conceito em mãos, é bastante fácil especificar uma
operação unitária U que funcione. Qualquer Matriz unitária que corresponda ao padrão mostrado na tela vai de fato
funcionar. As primeiras n colunas — assumindo que X tem n estados clássicos como antes — são obtidas empilhando as raízes quadradas das
matrizes que descrevem a medição umas sobre as outras, e as colunas restantes podem ser o que
quisermos — não faz diferença alguma, desde que a Matriz inteira seja unitária.
E a propósito, se você estiver notando uma semelhança com a conexão entre as representações de Kraus e Stinespring de canais, isso não é coincidência —
na verdade, o que temos aqui é essencialmente um caso especial disso, onde nossas matrizes de Kraus acontecem de ser todas positivas
semi-definidas. Então há duas coisas que precisamos verificar: a primeira é que essa escolha de U realmente funciona, e a
segunda é que é possível escolher as colunas não especificadas de forma que U seja unitária. Então vamos começar com a primeira.
Aqui está o estado com que começamos: o sistema Y de baixo é inicializado para o estado zero, enquanto o sistema de cima
começa no estado rho. Então realizamos U, o que significa que conjugamos por
U. Podemos escrever tudo em termos de matrizes em bloco como mostrado na tela. Temos U à esquerda, U daguer à
direita, e cat zero bra zero tensor com rho no meio, que tem a forma que temos aqui, com rho no
canto superior esquerdo e zeros em todo o resto. E se você pensar sobre esse produto por um momento, é evidente que as
entradas não especificadas de U não importam absolutamente nada, porque estão sempre sendo multiplicadas pelos zeros desta
Matriz do meio. E se trabalharmos a multiplicação, obtemos esta
Matriz mostrada aqui, descrita como uma Matriz em bloco. Ou alternativamente podemos expressá-la usando notação de somatória
assim. Essa é de fato a forma mais conveniente para nós, então vamos focar nessa
expressão. E por conveniência, vamos dar a essa Matriz — que é uma Matriz de densidade — o nome de
Sigma. O último passo é a medição de base padrão em y, então vamos calcular o estado reduzido de y, e
isso é fácil dada a expressão que temos: simplesmente traçamos X, que corresponde ao segundo fator
tensor. Então a probabilidade para qualquer dado resultado a aparecer é a entrada diagonal correspondente a a. Podemos escrever
isso assim, e é igual ao traço da raiz quadrada de PA vezes rho vezes a raiz
quadrada de PA. E pela propriedade cíclica do traço, obtemos o traço de PA vezes rho,
que era o que esperávamos. Então as probabilidades para os diferentes resultados aparecerem estão corretas — sempre concordam
com a medição original com que começamos. A segunda coisa que precisamos verificar
é que é possível preencher as colunas não especificadas de U de uma forma que a torne
unitária. Isso segue do fato de que as primeiras n colunas — que são aquelas formadas pelas raízes quadradas das matrizes que descrevem a
medição — são ortonormais, e isso pode ser verificado diretamente. Os detalhes relevantes estão aqui
na tela, então pause o vídeo e tome alguns momentos para pensar sobre isso se quiser. Mas como sugeri antes,
é na verdade um caso especial de algo que encontramos na aula anterior. E essa é a
prova. Até aqui na aula, mantivemos nosso foco em medições destrutivas — ou seja, sem especificação do
estado quântico pós-medição do sistema que foi medido. Para uma medição não destrutiva, por outro lado,
não há apenas um resultado clássico da medição, mas também um estado quântico pós-medição do sistema que foi medido. E como
veremos, há uma conexão natural com o teorema de Neymark. Na verdade, existem diferentes formas de formular medições não destrutivas
em termos matemáticos, mas vamos começar com uma formulação que vem diretamente do teorema de Neymark.
Considere uma medição geral — ou seja, uma medição destrutiva — descrita por uma coleção de matrizes positivas semi-definidas
p 0 até pN menos um que somam à identidade. Podemos então transformar isso
em uma medição não destrutiva simplesmente considerando a implementação dessa medição que discutimos no contexto do teorema de Neymark.
Introduzimos um novo sistema y, interagimos ele com X através de uma operação unitária U, e depois realizamos uma medição de base padrão
em y. Então o sistema X ainda está lá, e podemos considerar seu
estado. E com base na análise que fizemos, podemos determinar que o estado pós-medição de X condicionado
a obter um resultado particular da medição a é dado por uma Matriz de densidade que se parece com
isso. Em palavras, conjugamos pela raiz quadrada da Matriz de medição correspondente e depois
normalizamos. Outra forma de formular medições não destrutivas — que é mais geral — é em termos das matrizes de
Kraus de canais, e essa é a definição de medições que você encontrará no famoso livro-texto de Nielsen e
Chuang, por exemplo. Suponha que m0 até m M menos 1 são matrizes quadradas que satisfazem
a equação mostrada na tela — ou seja, poderíamos pensar nessas matrizes como sendo matrizes de Kraus que descrevem um
canal. Na verdade, essas matrizes descrevem um canal, mas também descrevem uma medição não destrutiva.
E a forma como funciona quando um sistema em um dado estado rho é medido é: primeiro, as probabilidades dos resultados são
dadas pela equação mostrada na tela — cada resultado aparece com probabilidade igual ao traço de ma vezes
rho vezes ma daguer. E condicionado ao resultado a aparecer, o estado do sistema
medido se parece com isso. Medições não destrutivas desse tipo podem ser implementadas de uma
forma similar ao que tínhamos para o teorema de Neymark, e deixo isso para você pensar se
quiser. É possível generalizar o conceito de medição não destrutiva ainda mais do que isso — por exemplo,
existe um conceito de instrumento quântico que às vezes é bastante útil, mas não vou tratar isso neste
vídeo. Na última parte da aula, vou discutir brevemente duas tarefas associadas às medições: discriminação de Estado Quântico e
tomografia de Estado Quântico. Há bastante a ser dito sobre esses dois conceitos, e vamos
apenas arranhar a superfície. Então vamos começar esclarecendo o que esses termos significam e como eles diferem.
Primeiro está a discriminação de estado quântico. A ideia aqui é que temos uma coleção conhecida de estados quânticos
de algum sistema junto com probabilidades associadas a esses estados. Para ser preciso, vamos assumir
que rho 0 até rho M menos 1 são matrizes de densidade representando possíveis estados quânticos de um sistema X, e p 0
até pN menos um são probabilidades associadas a esses estados. Então se coletarmos as probabilidades em um único
vetor, obtemos um vetor de probabilidade. Uma forma sucinta de dizer isso, a propósito, é que temos um ensemble de estados quânticos.
E agora uma forma abstrata de pensar na discriminação de estado quântico como uma tarefa ou como um problema
é que: primeiro, um número entre 0 e N menos um é escolhido aleatoriamente de acordo com as probabilidades. O sistema X é então
preparado no estado correspondente ao número selecionado aleatoriamente, e o objetivo é determinar, por
meio de uma medição de X, qual número foi escolhido. Então temos um número finito de
alternativas junto com uma prior, e o objetivo é determinar qual alternativa realmente aconteceu. Para algumas escolhas de estados e
probabilidades, isso pode ser fácil, e para outras pode não ser possível fazê-lo sem alguma chance de cometer um erro.
E há várias perguntas específicas que poderíamos fazer, como: qual é a probabilidade mínima de cometer um erro,
e como é uma medição que atinge essa probabilidade mínima de erro? A tomografia de Estado Quântico, por
outro lado, é diferente. Aqui temos um estado quântico desconhecido de um sistema — ou seja, normalmente
não há prior nem nenhuma informação sobre possíveis alternativas. Desta vez, porém, não é uma única cópia do estado que está
disponível, mas sim muitas cópias independentes — ou seja, para algum número possivelmente grande
n, temos n sistemas idênticos X1 até xn que são cada um preparado independentemente no estado
rho. E desta vez o objetivo é encontrar uma aproximação desse estado quântico desconhecido como Matriz de densidade, medindo
os sistemas. Então em resumo: na discriminação de estado quântico, temos uma única cópia
do estado e tentamos discriminar entre um número finito de alternativas conhecidas. E na tomografia de estado quântico, temos muitas cópias independentes
de um estado quântico desconhecido, e o objetivo é encontrar uma descrição desse estado, ou pelo menos uma boa aproximação
dele. A discriminação de estado quântico é interessante porque abstrai um tipo de situação que surge com frequência em
computação e criptografia, por exemplo, onde uma alternativa dentre um conjunto finito de possibilidades ocorreu e nós — ou outra pessoa — estamos tentando
descobrir qual foi, medindo um sistema quântico. O caso mais simples não trivial é
quando há apenas duas alternativas, ou seja, m é igual a dois. Portanto, a tarefa é discriminar entre um par
de estados. Esse caso acaba sendo essencialmente um problema completamente resolvido, assumindo que o objetivo é minimizar
a chance de uma discriminação incorreta. Há uma escolha ótima para uma medição, e ela é frequentemente chamada de
medição de Helstrom. É uma medição projetiva de fato, e pode ser descrita da seguinte
forma: primeiro consideramos a diferença ponderada entre as duas alternativas — ou seja, p 0 vezes rho 0 menos P1 vezes rho um.
Então estamos multiplicando a probabilidade de extrair cada um desses dois estados pelos próprios estados, e estamos tomando a
diferença. Essa é uma Matriz hermitiana porque é igual ao seu próprio transposto conjugado. Portanto, tem uma decomposição espectral
e sabemos em particular que os autovalores são todos números reais. Então vamos assumir que temos uma
decomposição espectral escrita na forma mostrada na tela. O que fazemos a seguir é coletar os
autovalores em dois conjuntos, onde todos os autovalores positivos estão em um conjunto e todos os autovalores negativos estão no
outro. Para ser preciso, vamos tomar S0 como sendo o conjunto de todos os índices k para os quais o autovalor correspondente Lambda K é
não-negativo, e S1 como sendo os índices restantes, que são os correspondentes a autovalores
negativos. Na verdade não importa qual conjunto contém os índices correspondentes a quaisquer autovalores zero — aqui estamos fazendo
uma escolha arbitrária de incluir o zero em S0, mas não faria nenhuma diferença se alguns ou todos eles estivessem incluídos em S1. O que realmente importa é
que estamos separando os autovalores positivos e negativos. E por fim, definimos duas projeções Pi
0 e Pi 1 como mostrado na tela. Em palavras, Pi 0 é a projeção sobre o
subespaço gerado pelos autovetores correspondentes a autovalores não-negativos, e Pi 1 é a projeção sobre o espaço
gerado pelos autovetores correspondentes a autovalores negativos. Essas são de fato projeções, e
se as somarmos, obtemos a Matriz identidade, porque os autovetores S 0 até S N menos um formam uma
base ortonormal. Se essa medição for realizada na situação em questão — ou seja, o
estado sendo medido é rho 0 com probabilidade p 0 e rho um com probabilidade P1 — então resulta que
a probabilidade de uma identificação correta tem uma fórmula bastante simples em termos dos autovalores Lambda 0 até Lambda n menos
um. Não vou mostrar os detalhes do cálculo neste vídeo — você pode consultar o conteúdo escrito linkado na descrição do vídeo se tiver
interesse, ou ver se consegue se convencer de que essa fórmula está correta. Também podemos expressar essa
probabilidade usando uma norma matricial comumente chamada de Norma de Traço. A notação é similar à norma euclidiana para vetores,
exceto que temos um subscrito de 1 para indicar que é a Norma de Traço. A Norma de Traço é muito importante e é
muito comumente encontrada em computação quântica, mas não vou dizer muito mais sobre ela nesta aula. Uma forma de
defini-la para matrizes hermitianas é que é a soma dos valores absolutos dos autovalores, então você pode pensar
nessa segunda igualdade como seguindo diretamente dessa definição. A norma de traço também pode ser
definida de outras formas mais gerais, e vamos encontrar a norma de traço novamente na próxima aula. Este é de fato
o melhor que você pode fazer — essa medição é ótima assumindo que seu objetivo é maximizar a chance de uma estimativa
correta. Esse fato às vezes é chamado de teorema de Helstrom-Holevo, e às vezes é chamado apenas de teorema de Helstrom.
Então você não consegue superar essa medição em termos de probabilidade de correção, e é bom porque
há uma receita simples para a própria medição e uma fórmula exata para a probabilidade de correção em termos da norma de
traço. A norma de traço é frequentemente usada como uma forma de medir a diferença observável entre matrizes de densidade
precisamente por essa razão. E quando as pessoas se referem à distância de traço entre estados, geralmente se referem a
metade da norma de traço da diferença entre as duas matrizes de densidade, o que aqui corresponde ao caso em que p 0 e P1 são ambos 1/2 —
que é um caso natural a considerar. A discriminação de estado quântico para dois estados é otimamente resolvida pela
medição de Helstrom, para a qual temos uma receita simples e uma fórmula simples para a probabilidade de
correção. Então o que acontece quando queremos discriminar entre três ou mais estados? Nesse caso não temos uma
fórmula geral para uma escolha ótima de medição ou uma expressão simples para a probabilidade máxima de
correção. É possível, no entanto, encontrar uma boa aproximação de uma medição ótima com a ajuda de um computador,
e em particular isso pode ser feito usando uma técnica de otimização realmente fascinante e poderosa conhecida como programação semi-definida. Mas não é
algo que você pode implementar de forma viável com um lápis e um pedaço de papel, por exemplo. Por outro lado, se alguém
te der uma descrição de uma medição e afirmar que essa medição é ótima para uma tarefa de discriminação de estado quântico, então
na verdade é muito fácil verificar ou refutar essa afirmação. E isso poderia ser feito usando as chamadas condições de Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax. Não vou explicar o que são neste vídeo, mas são condições simples, e é bem legal
que isso seja possível. Aqui está um exemplo que se conecta de volta aos estados tetraédricos
que vimos anteriormente na aula. Suponha que nos são dados um desses quatro estados selecionado aleatoriamente com
probabilidade um quarto para cada um, e nosso objetivo é determinar qual estado nos foi dado. Não é surpreendente, talvez, mas
a melhor escolha que você pode fazer para uma medição para isso é a medição tetraédrica. Você nem sempre pode fazer
algo assim para uma coleção arbitrária de estados puros, mas por causa das simetrias envolvidas aqui, isso
funciona, e obtemos de fato uma medição válida. E através das condições de Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax que mencionei
alguns instantes atrás, acaba sendo bastante simples provar que essa é de fato uma escolha ótima de
medição. Especificamente, o que acontece aqui é que a medição é sempre correta com probabilidade 1/2, o que não é
ruim porque há quatro alternativas — portanto, a probabilidade de uma estimativa correta é duas vezes melhor que o acaso aleatório. E
isso é o melhor que você pode fazer com esses estados. Agora vou dizer um pouco mais sobre a tomografia de Estado Quântico,
onde temos muitas cópias independentes de um estado quântico desconhecido e o objetivo é encontrar uma aproximação da Matriz de densidade que descreve
esse estado. Na verdade, existem várias variantes diferentes desse problema que dependem de suas suposições, e em
particular do tipo de medições que você permite. Por exemplo, poderíamos exigir que cada sistema seja medido individualmente e
os resultados sejam combinados de alguma forma para chegar a uma descrição da Matriz de densidade. Ou poderíamos permitir que todos os
sistemas sejam medidos juntos como um único sistema composto, o que é muito melhor em teoria, mas também muito mais
exigente do ponto de vista tecnológico. Além das escolhas que se faz para as medições, há
também uma consideração importante: como reconstruir uma descrição da Matriz de densidade a partir de qualquer dado que você
obtenha das medições. Não vou entrar em detalhes sobre isso — meu ponto é simplesmente sugerir
que a tomografia de Estado Quântico é realmente mais um conceito guarda-chuva com muitas variantes diferentes, ao invés de ser um
único procedimento. Houve uma grande quantidade de pesquisa sobre esse problema, incluindo alguns resultados de avanço bastante
recentes que conectam o número de cópias n à precisão da aproximação que pode ser obtida. E continua a ser uma
área de pesquisa interessante e ativa. Para terminar a aula, vamos dar uma olhada na tomografia de Estado Quântico
para qubits e como podemos fazê-la. Então vamos supor que rho é uma Matriz de densidade representando um estado de um
único qubit, e X1 até xn são qubits que foram todos preparados independentemente no estado rho. E para
fins desta discussão, vamos assumir que n é grande. O que podemos fazer é dividir os
sistemas em três pilhas aproximadamente iguais. E para a primeira pilha, realizaremos uma medição com relação à base mais-
menos. Para cada resultado correspondente a mais, marcaremos mais um, e para cada
resultado correspondente a menos, marcaremos menos um. Uma forma mais sucinta de descrever essa medição
é que é uma medição de Pauli X, porque os estados mais e menos são autovetores da Matriz de Pauli X e os
autovalores correspondentes são mais um e menos um. E na verdade essa também é uma forma muito mais comum de descrevê-la. E
de fato o valor esperado para a pontuação é igual ao traço de Sigma x vezes rho. Agora não necessariamente aprendemos qual é
esse valor esperado, mas se fizermos a média das pontuações que obtemos ao longo de muitas e muitas tentativas, é bastante provável que obtenhamos uma
aproximação razoável para esse valor esperado pela lei dos grandes números. E há alguns limites estatísticos bem conhecidos que podemos aplicar
se quisermos ser mais quantitativos sobre essa afirmação. Fazemos algo similar com Sigma y na segunda terça parte dos
sistemas. A única coisa que muda aqui é que usamos os estados mais i e menos i, que são autovetores de Sigma
Y. E de forma similar para Sigma Z, para o qual os vetores da base padrão são auto-
vetores. E então, por fim, podemos usar a fórmula mostrada na tela, que nos diz quais devem ser os coeficientes
se rho for escrito como uma combinação linear das matrizes de Pauli. E substituindo nossas aproximações para esses coeficientes
e possivelmente ajustando-os um pouco para garantir que obtenhamos uma Matriz positiva semi-definida, obtemos uma aproximação para
rho. É claro que há detalhes nos quais não entrei, como a precisão da aproximação e o grau de
confiança que podemos ter nela, mas esperamos que isso te dê uma ideia básica de uma forma como a tomografia pode ser realizada em um
qubit. Também é possível fazer a tomografia de qubit usando a medição tetraédrica, e na verdade isso acaba sendo
bastante simples e elegante, pelo menos em termos matemáticos. O que podemos fazer é realizar apenas
essa única medição em todas as cópias independentes do nosso Estado Quântico desconhecido, e usando a
fórmula notável mostrada aqui, podemos chegar a uma aproximação do nosso estado estimando o traço de PK vezes
rho para cada K pela fração de vezes que o resultado de medição correspondente aparece. Novamente, isso só funciona por causa das
simetrias perfeitas que temos entre esses quatro estados, e há de fato alguns problemas não resolvidos realmente fascinantes que se relacionam a generalizações
dessa abordagem para sistemas maiores. E esse é um bom lugar para parar a aula. Obrigado por assistir, e
espero que você se junte a mim para a próxima aula, que é sobre purificações e Fidelidade. Até mais!